let me ask you about
mars so
um there's a guy named elon musk
and uh he seems to want to take
something called dogecoin there
first of the moon i'm just i'm just
kidding about the tushcoin i
i don't even know what the what the heck
is uh up with that whole uh
i think uh i think humor
has power in the 21st century
in a way to spread ideas in the most
positive way
so i love that kind of humor
because it makes people smile but it
also kind of
sneak it's like a trojan horse for cool
ideas
you you open with humor and you uh like
the
humor is the appetizer and then the main
meal is the science and the engineering
anyway uh do you think
it's possible to colonize
mars or other planets in the solar
system but we're
especially uh looking to mars is there
something about planets that make them
very harsh
to humans is there something in
particular you think about
and maybe in a high like big picture
perspective do you have a hope we
we do in fact become a multi-planetary
species
i do think that if our species
survives long enough and we don't wipe
ourselves out or get wiped out by some
other means
that we will eventually be able to
colonize other planets
i do not expect that to happen in my
lifetime i mean
tourists may go to mars tourists people
who commit
years of their life to going to mars as
a tourist may go to mars
um i don't think that we will colonize
it
is there a sense why it's just too harsh
on an environment
to uh to to like it's too costly to
build something habitable there
for a large population
i think that we need to do a lot of work
and learning how to use the resources
that are
on the planet already to do the things
we need so if you're talking about
someone going there for a few months
[Music]
so back up a little bit there are many
things that make
mars not hospitable temperature you
can't breathe air
you need a pressure suit even if you're
on the surface the radiation environment
is you know even in all those things the
radiation environment is too harsh for
the human body
um all of those things seem like they
could eventually
have technological solutions
the challenge the the real
significant challenge to me seems to be
the the creation of a self-sustaining
civilization there you know you can
bring pressure suits you can bring
oxygen to breathe but those are all in
limited supply and if we're going to
colonize it we need to find
ways to make use of the resources that
are there to do things like produce food
produce the air the humans need to keep
breathing just in order to make it
self-sustaining there's a tremendous
amount of work that has to be done
and people are working on these problems
but
i think that's going to be a major
obstacle in going from
visiting where we can bring everything
we need to survive in the short term to
actually colonizing yeah
i find that whole project
of the human species quite inspiring
these like huge
moonshot projects somebody i was reading
something um in terms of the source of
food that's that may be the most
effective on mars
is you could farm insects that's the
easiest thing to farm
so we'll be eating like cockroaches
before living on mars because that's the
easiest thing to actually
um as a source of protein so growing a
source of protein
is the easiest thing is insects i just
imagine this giant
for people who are afraid of insects
this is not a pleasant
maybe you're not supposed to even think
of it that way it'll be like a cockroach
milkshake or something like that
right i wonder if have people been
working on the genetic
engineering of of insects to make them
more radiation friendly
right or pressure resistant or whatever
it makes them
what can possibly go wrong just make
them radiation resistant
they're already like survived everything
you